i want to get into the stuff that's
going on with the the democrats so we
have a couple stories that i want to
highlight and we'll go through this
quickly because i want to highlight the
political turmoil
not necessarily the democrats or the
republicans just the instability
so we have the story from cnn house
democrats way ejecting gop
winner of contested iowa race dismissing
comparisons to trump's effort to
overturn the election
quite literally this is a republican who
won the state certified she won
a bipartisan panel certified this
republican won
and the democrats have voted to move
forward with a review to see
if they will eject a republican sitting
member of congress who duly won her
election
and replace her with a democrat we also
have
73 democrats sign efforts to expel
marjorie taylor green from the house
after she's already been removed from
her committees
now we have them going after brett
kavanaugh with vanity fair writing could
brett kavanaugh be booted from the
supreme court
we talk a lot about politics i get it
but how much of this
is oh let's have an argument about who
did who who should be in the supreme
court
how much of this is our system is
completely gone it's broken
when the moment they said i know he's
already on the supreme court
let's reopen investigation anyway i know
she's literally a duly elected
representative
let's remove her now at what point do we
just say we have no elections
if they're going to be doing this after
the fact once again this relates to
what we've been talking about for the
last hour or so which is the complete
destruction of our institutional norms
for short-term convenience it's always
short-term convenience oh
with donald trump he's he's literally
hitler so we've got to uh uh get rid of
this whole objectivity thing for the
news media
yeah you know and then the military's
now now you know this slippery slope
now now the military well you know we've
had a civil military uh separation for
uh 204 years
we'll just spark the biggest crisis in
civil military relations since uh
macarthur
because cause because tucker said things
we think are mean
he did say mean things though you know
and those and and we as very soft
delicate cookie dough americans can't
handle mean words
you know words are violence at least
that's what they've been telling me now
so when i i mean look at us we're
sitting here talking about
you know you literally having dealt with
the la riots
and having deployed and served in the
military much more than i can speak for
uh
but i've been in riots as well and i'm
looking at a bunch of people that think
words are violence
like okay i watched someone get shot i i
personally got
shot by a ricochet of a pepper ball
which sprayed my face
with plastic bits and went my eyes and
and took me down a bit
i've run through walls of tear gas in
turkey and brazil
and the united states and i'm not going
to pretend like i'm some super soldier
i'm just some dude who's actually seen
some stuff but
if i've seen that and we've got one the
political conflict
the institutional breakdown our military
is freaking out about gadsden flags
every little institution like you
mentioned they're breaking apart
confidence in the system is breaking
moral frameworks are have
there's two different total moral
frameworks it feels like in my
opinion we are heading towards well what
do we call a prepper's dream
what they've they've long i mean i'll
tell you this i see these these twitter
posts from preppers
and they post how they're laughing i
remember i was i drove uh at the
beginning of covid
i drove across the u.s i was i went to a
gas station
and you know the toilet paper craze and
i asked the
the the you know the lady at the counter
and we were in arizona
and she goes oh we're not worried about
any of that we're preppers
we got months worth of everything
stocked up and always have so we laugh
at everybody when this happens
so i i'll try i want to try and keep it
wrapped up in you know just stemming
into the political conversation vanity
fair is actually asking if they could
boot brett kavanaugh because
who was it was it a senator was it white
house white house said the fbi didn't
actually do
a legitimate review it was fake so
they're trying to reignite
yeah they said that a lot of people were
trying to send tips to the fbi about
kavanaugh
but apparently chris wray was classmates
with kavanaugh
and they're both members of the
federalist society so ray didn't
actually do the investigation
they're trying to get pretext it seems
to remove a supreme court justice
to remove two gop reps they already took
marjorie taylor green off of her
her committees i bring this up just to
talk about the institutional decay
to say like at what point does this stop
and do we recover
or is this just the the crumbling of the
infrastructure that leads to the chaos
there's there's going to be one one or
two directions
either it continues and there's chaos or
people say whoa
stop now we saw uh that young lady
canceled
uh today a very liberal lady canceled a
a a woman of uh
a leftist woman of color was fired or
she was forced to resign and jonathan
swann got on twitter and said this is
terrible this is wrong of course
he got ratioed with people going this is
what you wanted
yeah this is what you've been cheering
uh either people stop it
or it continues what what is rewarded
you get more of
and so far this stuff has been rewarded
always
if it goes on i mean it's ugly look i
i've got five
novels of america falling apart that's i
sell a ton of people's republic go get
your copy today
people were actually commenting they
said that they uh one person commented
they read your book and loved it and
it's eerily similar to what's happening
it worries them
it it it kind of freaks me out because
when i wrote the first one people's
republic in 2016.
it was a warning i love this country i
love what we have here i've lived
overseas for years
i've seen places that don't work and it
and it rips me up to see us squandering
the legacy we've been granted
we didn't earn it we didn't build it
here we were handed it we need to
maintain it we're not doing that sounds
like obama remember
you didn't build that well in this case
it's correct yeah we did not build these
institutions we inherited it
we could have made them better but you
know
we we've already gone down that road so
i wrote these books and i was thinking
you know what's the wildest thing you
know uh people
what craziness uh people being arrested
for
uh being transphobic uh you know thought
i was that there was that guy who got
arrested because he
i think it was in canada that was canada
yeah he refused to refer to his
daughter is his daughter uh yeah yes
well
this is complicated you know it's it's a
court battle between
the the parents and the court as to
whether or not the child has the right
to be
the 13 year old yeah maybe 14.
so the issue is if it was a clear-cut
case where we had quotes from
a you know trans boy a transgender you
know 14 year old who said specifically
they were
then i can talk about what that person
was saying we have a legal battle
when you have a judge saying i don't
care what your legal argument is about
your children you must say this or you
know what i mean
seems like they've already decided right
so and we saw that other legal battle
in texas well that that's you know
again institutional decay when but back
to your book i don't want to derail from
your
your time up about the book go buy the
damn book
all five of them you were mentioning you
were mentioning that people were getting
arrested for like crazy things yeah eric
and i write this stuff and it starts
happening and i'm thinking successively
more crazy stuff as i'm writing the
subsequent books and it's happening and
people write me going
this is all happening and it's like i
don't want this to happen
this is not a hell too i'm not for any
of this
but they don't listen it it's this
institutional decay
look what institution defends us
regular people now can you go to the
courts and be
sure that you're going to get a fair
shake can you go to the fbi can you go
to
congress can you go to the media can you
go to academia academia's going to tell
you you're uh
you're you know you're a white
supremacist which was really published
puzzling to the guy who drives a truck
for a living when he's being told by a
guy who makes four times as much you
know
uh uh doing diversity articles uh that
that he's oppressing sounds like you're
saying we already lost
i don't think we've ever you made it you
made a really scary point i'll tell you
that
think about this for everybody listening
do you feel like if you went to court
if you called the police if you called
the fbi for any for any issue do you
think they would actually have
your back would they support you as an
american citizen would you get a fair
shot would you get a fair shot see the
the beauty of
a democratic republic a free country
is you know maybe you lose the election
but you're like well okay i lost
but you know i lost be i i made my case
better luck next time or i went to court
i didn't like the way the jury came out
but
i got a chance to make my piece and i
think it was fair right that's that's
the basis and you don't have that
youtube has a rule
that if you say something specific in
relation to donald trump in the election
they'll delete
your video and give you a strike donald
trump's made statements that have been
removed from youtube
and his own speeches have gotten
people's
news outlets like right side
broadcasting network out of strike i
believe simply for broadcasting trump's
speech
yet if you relay what the democrats have
said about rita hart in iowa
which is in many ways similar to what
donald trump said
you are fine you are allowed to advocate
for what the democrats have called for
contesting a certified election that's
okay on youtube
that's that's that's that's the silicon
valley bias right there
well it's hugely biased and i think
it's another example short-term thinking
because right now well it's such an
emergency
we've got to do this exceptional thing
of course the exception becomes the rule
when it becomes the rule it eventually
becomes the rule for everybody
and the worm eventually turns
and someday they could be scratching
their heads going gosh
i don't seem to have a lot of friends
left
i look i don't think we've ever lost
until our heart stopped bleep beating
i i am always an optimist i understand
that
what we had in america and what i think
we're on the verge of losing if we don't
watch it
is so much greater than what's been in
any other culture any other place uh
certainly any other place i've been
there's something about it it's so
powerful it's so right
you know and i'm not one of those guys
the right side of
history oh god but what we what we're
selling
freedom civil rights individuality free
enterprise
uh the rule of law this is great stuff
and people have sacrificed a huge amount
for it
and people from other countries like my
wife come here
to get that so i'm calling a pipe though
look it's running right but we're not
done yet and i i will never give up as
long as i'm alive
i will never give up and just say uh
we're done no i agree
i will certainly use their rules against
them because some people need to learn
through pain
i guess the issue is when
the right does anything that the left
does they're held to a very very strict
standard
if conservatives go out and protest they
call it you know a far-right
insurrection
revolt with the left that's what they'll
call it a peaceful protest of course and
we gotta understand that uh
you know the media and the establishment
are our opponents
uh i think that's one reason you see
fewer conservatives being canceled now
is that it it no longer works on us
we have enough of our own
outlets it's not perfect you can get
canceled off youtube you might have to
go someplace else
but we can still get our message out
there and they can't cancel us
so they're turning inward thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time